one of the four cubs born to and then maybe
in cheater relocated to India as part of a
reintroduction program and died on Tuesday.
Forest department officials say that the cub
is to believe to have died -- it was the
fourth cup to die in nearly two months.
CNN's Ivan Watson has the story.
>> A safe night scene in India,
for more than 70 years. A leader of cheetah cubs,
born two months ago. She is one of AIDS and maybe
into does brought last year to India's qanon
national park. Hunting and habitat love to the
extension of two dozen in India in 1952. But
a planned decades in the making is returning
these fast felines to India. Last of, tempered
emails and five females made the long journey.
[3:38:46 AM]
journey. The arrival of the two-dose
coincided with the birthday of Indian
premised or narendra Modi. Who celebrated
the release to a special quarantine zone.
>> Today the today has returned to the Indian
soil. And I would also say that along with
these two does, the nature loving countries in
India has also been awakened with full force.
>> In February, authorities shipped a second group
of additional cheetos from south Africa to India.
Veterinary wildlife specialist an associate
professor helped choose the best cast for the.
>> There was a few criteria that we were
interested in for the young animals. Obviously,
the ratio of the animals to gain. And then
we also wanted to make sure that they were
making quite a high lipid density. We wanted
animals that were wild and used to be with other
[3:39:46 AM]
wild and used to be with other
large carnivores and zone.
>> For wild animals like these, a journey of up
to 20 hours can induce high levels of stress.
>> And then successful acclimatization is not
guaranteed. In recent weeks, four of the T
does -- including one of the cubs. Some experts
have criticize the product from the start >> My
problem, the sun is an adequate, an India just
does not have the space. How do we do, to go
back to the drawing board. To cure the habitat. .
>> These big cats have a long history in India,
they are mentioned in each incense grips techs and
Indian royalty use them for hunting for centuries.
>> The Indian government now
plans to introduce 50 more of
[3:40:47 AM]
plans to introduce 50 more of these
big cats over the next five years.
The dream behind this high
stakes project for these wild